we also need investments in research and development.
So what might that look like?
In 1966, the US invested about a half a percent of gross domestic product
in the Apollo program.
It got people safely to the moon
and back to the earth.
Half a percent of GDP today is about 100 billion dollars.
So knowing that direct air capture
is one front in our fight against climate change,
imagine that we could invest 20 percent, 20 billion dollars.
Further, let's imagine that we could get the costs down
to a 100 dollars a ton.
That's going to be hard, but it's part of what makes my job fun.
And so what does that look like,
20 billion dollars,100 dollars a ton?
That requires us to build 200 synthetic forests,
each capable of capturing a million tons of CO2 per year.
That adds up to about five percent of US annual emissions.
It doesn't sound like much.
Turns out, it's actually significant.
If you look at the emissions associated with long-haul trucking
and commercial aircraft,
they add up to about five percent.
Our dependence on liquid fuels makes these emissions
really difficult to avoid.
So this investment could absolutely be significant.
Now, what would it take in terms of land area to do this,
200 plants?
It turns out that they would take up about half the land area of Vancouver.
That's if they were fueled by natural gas.
But remember the downside of natural gas -- it also emits CO2.
So if you use natural gas to do direct air capture,
you only end up capturing about a third of what's intended,
unless you have that clever approach of co-capture
that Carbon Engineering does.
And so if we had an alternative approach
and used wind or solar to do this,
the land area would be about 15 times larger,
looking at the state of New Jersey now.
One of the things that I think about in my work and my research
is optimizing and figuring out where we should put these plants
and think about the local resources available --
whether it's land, water, cheap and clean electricity --
because, for instance, you can use clean electricity
to split water to produce hydrogen,
which is an excellent, carbon-free replacement for natural gas,
to supply the heat required.
But I want us to reflect a little bit again on negative emissions.
Negative emissions should not be considered a silver bullet,
but they may help us if we continue to stall
at cutting down on CO2 pollution worldwide.
But that's also why we have to be careful.
This approach is so alluring that it can even be risky,
as some may cling onto it as some kind of total solution to our climate crisis.
It may tempt people to continue to burn fossil fuels 24 hours a day,
365 days a year.
I argue that we should not see negative emissions
as a replacement for stopping pollution,
but rather, as an addition to an existing portfolio that includes everything,
from increased energy efficiency
to low-energy carbon
to improved farming --
will all collectively get us on a path to net-zero emissions one day.
A little bit of self-reflection:
my husband is an emergency physician.
And I find myself amazed by the lifesaving work
that he and his colleagues do each and every day.
Yet when I talk to them about my work on carbon capture,
I find that they're equally amazed,
and that's because combatting climate change by capturing carbon
isn't just about saving a polar bear
or a glacier.
It's about saving human lives.
A synthetic forest may not ever be as pretty as a real one,
but it could just enable us to preserve not only the Amazon,
but all of the people
that we love and cherish,
as well as all of our future generations
and modern civilization.
Thank you.
(Applause)